what percent of women would you say
want to be wives and what percent of
women would you say our wives i want to
hear from the men
and your experience with dating
carry on the conversation that's you
right there
i'm choosing the girl
i'm choosing to go last i bet a lot
lie to themselves
so i bet it's higher than they think
so i'm going to say about 80 want to be
wives yeah only furry
30 are wives yeah okay yeah i think i
would
i would agree a lot with that i think a
lot of women want to be wives but they
don't have the substance or the skills
to actually
support as a lifestyle of the person
that they would ideally like to be with
so then they end up with somebody that
is not fully compatible with and they go
oh my relationship's all right it will
it will last and you know we have our
ups and downs and they have those sorts
of tumultuous relationships that don't
really work out long term
but most women don't have the the skill
sets to be
wives to the men that they aspire to be
with and what skills would you say those
are
patience
communication i think communication is
one of the most the most powerful ones
because
a lot of women have
in my experience at least have a lot of
self doubt and they don't
they don't know how to be supportive to
somebody else they don't know how to
communicate powerfully with somebody
else in a way that
helps their relationship to grow helps
their relationship to flourish and helps
their relationship to be really
effective
do you think women have self-doubt
because i find them to be more
narcissistic than ever
yeah is it is it a fake narcissistic
though because it's like an external
narcissism but an internal i don't feel
good about this i don't feel i'm worth
it
no
i feel like
i'll just like even at carnival i was
asking like rate yourself one to ten and
they would say ten i'm like oh god again
okay and then i'd ask i'd say well
aren't you perfect doesn't mean you're
perfect she's like well i'm not perfect
but i am and then they'd say special but
isn't it kind of narcissistic to think
you're special yeah like
everyone thinks they're special like
it's been proven in psychology that
everyone thinks they're above average
yeah i think they like to fib a lot to
not hurt everyone's feelings so i i was
single for six years nothing and then
this year i've just started getting back
into the dating game but the ones who
did text back all said the same thing i
would happily be your friend we never
talked again so why say we're not going
to be friends we know we're not going to
be friends
and to say hannah you say everyone
thinks they're above average when i rate
myself i fully give myself a five
because i don't feel like i'm better
than anyone and i don't feel like anyone
should be better than me probably a four
so four yeah are you rating yourself for
four you're saying no you're definitely
more than a four bro i know
when it comes to rating
what criteria are we using like are we
using what scale of one or ten in terms
of how good we are as a partner or how
attractive we are what's creating i'm
always talking about looks
okay so i'm always just talking about
looks wonderful
still rate myself for five because here
what
cool i got hype but i'm scoring it in
comparison to most most people i've
interact with right
um
again i'm not i haven't even got a full
beard
my beard don't connect so already i'm
i'm out i'm out of the market
so so i don't actually think you
answered what percent of women do you
think our wives what person that want to
be wives and what percent are and then
i'm gonna let the girls answer yeah i
didn't answer that um i think a hundred
percent of women want to be wise with
contingencies a hundred percent you
think the girls in those videos want to
be wives
yeah
okay
with the contingencies in the sense of
like they run me 10 grand a month
yeah
but that's not a real wife right so like
what percent of women actually want to
be wives you have to say like actually
want to be a wife with what it comes
with in the traditional sense um i would
say be what men want
what was it i think i heard like what
did you just say john right i think i
said it's james by the way
sorry sorry i still apologize that's
right um i said 70 i think 17 or 18 and
30. actually and then just i would say
81 and less than 10 yeah i'm i'm going
with 25.
25. one and four one and four are wives
one and four always and what percent
want to be
the rest oh you think all girls want to
be i don't think all girls want to be
wives i feel like they won't i just i
can't you can't be doing this [ __ ] i
want to deal with that i just
yeah 100
it is just like
like and you look at girls instagrams
and like the way it's like
oh you can't you can't say
but at the same time i'm still sticking
in like
here's the fence right you're right okay
okay i'm hopeful
like here's the fence we already know
only fans have really made how many
billion from for women but i'm still
like
i'm getting closer to the feds but i'm
still on i'm still off the fence
i'm hopeful
i mean i've been growing up on christian
values so yeah what about you guys what
do you think so just to be clear are you
asking what percentage of women like
want to be wives in the sense that they
want to be stay at home full-time um not
necessarily
stay at home like they want to be a
man's help mate i would say that's the
best way to put it i make money you help
me make money yeah and so whether like
some some girls are wives in the fact
they're more like executive assistant
type wives
some girls are wives and the fact you
know they're stay-at-home my mom type
wives
like it's not it's not a one some some
do the you know like they both get a job
you know and just but but the the key is
that they're submitting to the man oh i
think
around 40
40 of women want that or actively know
they want that
because most women think that submission
is a bad thing
okay they think that they they they want
to be empowered and they think that
submission means being a man's slave
so i think only 40 of women
have that awareness to realize that like
it's not a bad thing
and to the second percentage i would say
10 percent actually our wives yeah
and why do you say that why is it so
little
because
nowadays most women like a most women
have this oh i'm a strong independent
woman vibe
where they tell themselves they don't
even want a relationship in the first
place or they want to focus on their
careers
of the women who want to be in
relationships they still think that
submission or femininity is backwards or
a bad thing so i think only 10 of women
actively want that and they have that
yeah it seems quite london-centric as
well like women that that want to be the
boss they want to be the leader they
want to be
more career driven et cetera and less
sort of alluding to wanting to be wives
are like london has that in abundance
more like outside the countryside it's a
little bit different
yeah what do you think
i would say
about 25
are probably married
i would say about 45 percent
are wanting to be married but not in
that state yes
and the rest are not interested of being
married simply because
um that divide between being the wife
and being maybe the psychic
and
some women
probably um prefer to be the sergeant
because they feel like well i can just
have the fun bit and i don't have to do
all the other bits that comes into a
relationship and it's not because
they devalue themselves but they feel
like
maybe some insecurities in themselves
where they feel that they are not enough
to be a wife so they'll settle for
second mess when they forward i can
still have the man i want in my kind of
head but just have it on that kind of
tip do you think women want that long
term
well being a sergeant yeah
um reality it wouldn't happen in their
head they think it would happen for some
of them um
which is a harsh truth but it's the
reality for some women and i think
because of maybe ongoing heartbreaks or
putting their
heart and soul into someone that they
thought they could trust and build and
just constantly being put down or
putting themselves down
and
they just think you know what it is what
it is and that's how some women how some
women have come in reality in society
do you guys think we'll ever see the
pendulum swing back where instead of sex
schools we'll start to see finishing
schools come back
i did the bouquet of flowers real quick
as many of you know i was just banned on
tic tac and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible